vous êtes notre spécialiste intelligence
économique et vous avez noté un virage à
180 degrés dans ce domaine partout en
europe poutine mais les européens au
pied du mur ah oui c'est extraordinaire
il ya encore quelques semaines l'europe
de la défense c'était parce qu'elle est
maintenant aujourd'hui alors faut
rappeler qu'il ya eu là proclame la
publication de la boussole stratégique
c'est une idiotie en europe donc on sait
à peu près quelles sont les menaces et
on sait à peu près maintenant comment
ils répondront ensemble dans cette
boussole stratégique et ben il va y
avoir une force de réaction rapide 5000
hommes à commandement mutualiser des
programmes militaires en commun bref qui
vaille art de nouvelles règles et juste
avant le conflit on n'était pas sûr
d'autoriser dans les financements de
développement durable les financements
dans l'industrie militaire tout ça s'est
mis au placard et donc on va pouvoir du
mieux financer toute l'industrie
européenne les investissements dans la
défense devrait grimper à oui c'est très
clair nous bon ça date d'avant la guerre
en ukraine ça a été poussé par le
président entre hommes qui reprochait à
l'europe de ne pas consacrer au moins 2%
de son pib à la défense c'est clair il
ya une augmentation très clair un
chiffre en 2016 d'union européenne
c'était à peu près 200 milliards d'euros
d'investissements dans le la défense
aujourd'hui c'est 250 milliards us à 27
donc sans nos amis britanniques donc
l'effort il est là c'est le deuxième
budget militaire du monde derrière les
états unis mais on se doute bien qu'en
réalité la chine est au dessus de ses
200 milliards mais les chiffres
officiels de la chine mais quand même la
chine en troisième position et puis il
ya eu quand même la création du fonds
européen de défense qui était bon prévu
là encore plutôt à 12,3 milliards et qui
finalement est tombée à 9 milliards dans
les négociations bon 9 milliards d'euros
c'est quand même pas mal entre 2021 et
2027 une défense européenne normalement
cela signifie une industrie européenne
oui là c'est là que ça le bât blesse en
très très clairement pourtant l'agencé
européenne de défense qui a été créée en
deux mille quatre étaient chargés
justement de réfléchir à la cohérence de
tout ce système il ya eu des rapports
disant qu'on n'était pas suffisamment
cohérents les uns avec les autres 27 et
à 27 petite armée mais pas de cohérent
il ya des rapports montrant que tout ça
nous coûtait nous coûtait 25 milliards
minimum d'euros en plus chaque année du
fait d'achats d'instruments et d'outils
militaires essentiellement évidemment
aux états unis rendez vous compte il ya
six programme de frégates en europe il y
as en europe beaucoup plus de
constructeurs de véhicules blindés que
deux constructeurs de véhicules civils
s'étaient donc il faut revoir tout ça il
faut un peu plus de cohérence il va
falloir aussi plus de consolidation il
va falloir en effet qui émerge des
géants vraiment des grosses
multinationales européennes dans le
domaine de la défense l'union européenne
l'a compris dans ce domaine normalement
elle promet dans les prochains mois
d'avoir des résultats en attendant
certains pays ne compte pas jouer la
carte européenne donc clairement donc
l'allemagne l'allemagne qui annonce
c'est quand même un virage d'aussi à
180° 100 milliards dans les deux
prochaines années consacrer à la défense
pour quoi faire pour acheter des f-35
américains pour acheter des hélicoptères
lourds américains pour acheter des
patrouilleurs américain donc évidemment
ça va poser un certain nombre de
problèmes au sein de l'europe et les
négociations vont porter évidemment dans
cette absence de cohésion on n'attend ni
mais que la commission européenne publie
une liste d'équipements indispensables
dont bénéficient pas l'armement européen
qui devra pour le coup faire l'objet
d'investissements européens pour
l'europe merci beaucoup elle est là et
10 pour toutes ces précisions